depuis près de 100 ans sont organisées
partout en france des chantiers
bénévoles pour le parc de chevreuse
ils sont devenus internationaux depuis
2007 ce qui a fait naître un partenariat
entre la mairie de bonnel et études et
chantiers ile de france
deux groupes de jeunes se sont mobilisés
cette année pour ces chantiers sur
quatre communes
les molières bonnel jouars-pontchartrain
égaliser projets sont là justement pour
permettre pendant deux semaines une vie
collective autour d'eux c'est cette
quinzaine de personnes de prendre vie et
donc d'arriver sur le territoire et
d'impulser un petit un nouveau
commentaire
un nouveau départ à une ouverture de
sentiers justement comme on le fait ici
à revaloriser du patrimoine local à
sensibiliser aussi au développement
durable et au respect de la nature à
valoriser ce bel espace qu'une parc
naturel des bénévoles qui donnent de
leur temps pour apporter leur
contribution à différents projets ces
chantiers permettent de favoriser le
développement local et les rencontres et
échanges avec les populations de toutes
origines
hello my name is more au bio real life
rome mexico
là on avait simplement à l'avoir qui
sortent de terre et puis d'un marécage
on dire partout quoi et on dégage on en
découvre et qui avait dû peuvent
dépasser un peu partout autour un bassin
et du cou
ça se joue sur un violon un peu
découvert on nous disait pas c'est pas
vraiment ce qui est en dessous vous
allez voir au fur et à mesure et du coup
on a eu des bonnes petites surprises
une réussite à la fois pour le parc de
chevreuse et pour chacune des communes
qui prévoit déjà un avenir pour les
sites remis en valeur
on avait dans le bois des anciennes
carrières de pierres meulières et
c'est des trous qui ont été beaucoup
envahi par des
dg de déchets verts de déchets divers
etc
on va avoir un coin
avec parcours santé avec une promenade
dans le bois ou si on va refaire les
allées et puis donc d'anciennes
carrières qui vont être valorisés en
plus on va autour de sa raconter
l'histoire de ces carrières de grès qui
sont importantes pour les molières et la
vallée de chevreuse 3 trois sites ont
été nettoyés rénové remis en valeur à
l'avoir et de fontaines qui vont
réapparaître dans l'histoire de la
commune parce qu'ils étaient avait
disparu vraiment dans la broussaille et
donc voilà des séries protat vont
pouvoir à nouveau appréhendé ce ce beau
patrimoine
et puis le rêve c'est peut-être qu'un
jour ce lavoir trouve ça sa charpente
cette couverture et qu'il redevienne un
vrai lieu de promenade
chacun des jeunes repart avec le sourire
et des souvenirs plein la tête
ces chantiers se termine
traditionnellement par un pot de clôture
avec animation et dégustation de
spécialités culinaires préparées par les
jeunes bénévoles ils ne demandent qu'une
chose recommencer l'expérience
[Musique]
m